people say that by the way about
personal crms like you did the whole
idea that no one you know there's like
Salesforce which is like a CRM tool for
businesses to like remind you of people
you need to Ping and where they are in
your sales cycle Etc and a bunch of
companies have tried to do that for
personal things like birthday reminders
or like when's the last time you spoke
to so and so for your network
development and a bunch of people push
back against that people say like oh you
know you're making it unnatural you're
making it like this automated like
you're just managing human beings and
those are humans you shouldn't do that
and so it just depends on where you sit
on the spectrum of wanting to do that or
not I actually don't care if if I give
this piece of advice and I say that this
is the life tender is something that
helped me if it's not for you that's
totally okay like if you don't want to
systematize your relationship that's
fine and I'm not going to tell you that
I think you're going to get a divorce
because you're not doing it like I just
won't say anything it's not you know if
you have a great relationship without
doing these things I think that's
awesome if you talk to your wife tons
and you somehow with a newborn find time
to have these discussions daily you're
like a superhero in my book that's a
amazing we don't do that it's very
difficult I find and so doing these
things finding these little systems I
find is just super super helpful yeah
May I'm fully fully on on the same page
with you on this I've tried so many
different systems for personal CRM over
the years never quite stuck to one yeah
but the thing I'll come back to is I
actually have a list in my Apple notes
just of people I want to stay in touch
with and the other day I was inviting
some friends over for dinner and I just
I was thinking have I have I invited
everyone I I think I've invited the
people that I I think I want to group up
with this thing and I just thought you
know what let me just consult the list
and I realized oh I actually should
invite this person but I didn't think of
them in that group because that group is
University friends and University
friends I lump as like a category in my
mind but this person I met sort of
outside University but he gel with the
group so I saw his name on the list
that's a great idea messaged him and
he's coming and now he's going to meet
my meet my uni friends and just the by
virtue of the fact I have a list of
friends I want to stay in touch with it
is now encouraging those connections to
happen I did this at one point with
people in cities so once College ended
and I was no longer like with my core
group of friends in one place everyone
had moved all over the place like people
were starting jobs in different cities
different countries whatever I realized
that I needed to be deliberate when I
traveled about making sure that like if
I was in London I need to make sure that
I see my couple of friends that are in
London that I know I like really want to
see and so I made a list of like in
these big cities that I might be going
to who are the like five people that I
know in those cities and it's a reminder
for me because like LinkedIn is okay for
that you can sometimes like search who
to you know who are my first year
connections but you know this at scale
LinkedIn becomes a travesty like it's a
real disaster for me at this point and
so I can't really use it for that and so
having like a little list of that like
what's my little black book of people
that I know in these different cities is
actually a you know remarkable little
hack but yeah people like this sorry to
cut you off the systematizing uh
relationships thing does really bother
some people
um and I'm just a big believer that like
systems is actually a misnomer people
when they hear systems they start to
think like oh we're becoming robots and
we're not going to have a normal
conversation and like you know when
people will read my content they're like
oh you know he must not be normal in
person because you're not able to just
like have a conversation with someone
that's not what it is to me it's like
finding little heuristics shortcuts ways
to save yourself time and energy that
make your life easier in some way that
make your life better and easier
um you know at whatever it is you're
doing and so why not have those for
relationships the same way you would for
work hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day